lebanon's top prosecutor has ordered all
suspects detained over the 2020 Beirut
Port blast to be released more than 200
people were killed when chemicals
stocked in a warehouse caught fire
causing the explosion the prosecutor has
also filed charges against the judge
overseeing the case let's bring in
Aya Majid from Beirut she's the deputy
director for the Middle East at Amnesty
International hi thanks so much for
being on the program talk us through
today's developments why are they
significant
um I mean we see this as really a battle
for lebanon's future are we going to
have a kind of country where those
individuals who are responsible for
blowing up the country are held
accountable or one where they're allowed
to escape accountability
um as you know the invest the domestic
investigation into the Beirut Blast has
been suspended now for almost 13 months
on Monday the lead investigator issued
an opinion a legal opinion that he said
would allow him to move forward with the
investigation and on that basis he
charged eight individuals including the
top public prosecutor Asana in relation
to the blast and he also ordered the
release of five of the 17 detainees Who
currently remain in detention since
August and September of 2020. uh
obviously the political establishment
then all rallied uh around him they said
that he did not have the power to move
the investigation forward that the
investigation was still stalled and
today uh this culminated with the public
prosecutor who himself is charged in the
case and who had recused himself from
being involved in the very last case due
to his familiar relations to some of the
defendants previously he issued a
decision to remove uh to release all of
the detainees in the case effectively
bypassing the lead investigator in the
case and we're now also hearing reports
that he has decided to file uh charges
against bitar and has sent Security
Forces to guitar's home to notify him
about these charges and that a travel
ban has been imposed against him
um I mean all of this is really very
comfortable you know it's a very
complicated uh legal situation but we
you know all this to say is that the
political establishment the ruling
establishment are doing everything that
they can to prevent judge Target retired
from moving forward with the
investigation they are doing everything
that they can to prevent uh the truth
from coming out and for those high-level
officials responsible for the blast to
be held to account yes I guess to sort
of break it down for our International
audience there are a lot of
complications going on in terms of that
those legal proceedings but why have
efforts to interrogate top officials
over this explosion been hindered over
the course of the last three years
um so since the end of the Civil War
there really has been a culture of
impunity uh in Lebanon where
um you know top officials have not been
held accountable for any crimes against
the population including you know major
human rights violations
um but I tried to challenge that
narrative and he started charging very
top-level officials so you know heads of
security agencies uh the former prime
minister uh former ministers and of
course then there was a very uh
coordinated attack against him to
prevent those interrogations from moving
forward and they used every tool that
they had they started with
misinformation campaigns against the
judge calling him a foreign agent they
staged protest against him which turned
violent and led to uh seven deaths they
then instrumentalized those deaths to
say that title was driving the country
to Civil War and they also filed legal
challenge after a legal challenge after
bitar that led to the investigation
being suspended multiple times the last
legal challenge is that the defendants
the politicians were accused in the case
filed against beta have led to the
investigation being suspended since
December of 2021.
okay well thank you very much for your
analysis on this breaking news and no
doubt we'll cross back to it throughout
the day I am majub the deputy director
for the Middle East at Amnesty
International thank you
thank you